hey and welcome
today we're going to take a look at how
we can build modern web apps 100 in java
so we're going to use the bottom web
framework
along with spring boot and we're going
to spend today just building an app from
scratch just so i can show you some of
the core concepts and give you an idea
of how simple it can be to build a web
app
[Music]
so we're going to start off on spring
initializer
and we're just going to go with the
defaults here except i'm going to choose
java 17
and then we're going to add a few
dependencies here so first of all we are
going to build a full stack application
meaning we want to have some way of
persisting data i'm going to use spring
data jpa
i'm going to use an h2 database
and then i mentioned we're going to use
bottin as the web framework
and then we're going to use
the spring boot dev tools
to help us develop more quicker
let's hit generate
and
check out the project that we've
downloaded we are going to open it up in
intellij in my case
and if we take a look at what the
project has in it it doesn't have a
whole lot it has this spring booth
application launcher so just the main
method
kickstarting the springboot application
and nothing else
in the
pom file you can see we have
dependencies that we uh defined
including the vadin framework here
so
in order to get started i'm going to
just walk you through some of the basic
concepts of bottom so let's create a new
main view here that we could use for
going through some of those
so like i mentioned button allows you to
build web apps fully in java so we're
not going to write any html or
javascript even though that's
essentially what's going to run in the
browser at the end so let's take a look
at how we do that
so i'm going to first of all tell
botton that
this
view should be mapped to the empty route
so that just the context root and we're
going to extend from a vauden layout
class
vertical layout meaning that any
components we put in here will get
stacked vertically on top of each other
all right so we'll create a constructor
here in here we're going to add a
header one component just saying the
classic hello world
and with this we now have a very
bare-bones bottom application you can go
ahead and run it here
by running the springboot application
and
let's give that a couple moments to get
started
all right so with the app running let's
go to localhost on port 8080 and we can
see our hello world here
so let's take a look at first of all
some of the just basic concepts of
working with wadden so in bottom
everything is a component so if we
wanted a button
we would initialize a new button
component
like this we can give it a caption
click me like that
um equally we could do a text field for
instance so let's create a text
field and initialize that to a new
text field like this
and once we have components we can
display them by putting them into
layouts
so in our case we can call add and then
we can pass in the text field and the
button like this
all right and then we're going to build
a project so springboard devtools notice
is the change
and if all goes well we'll see that we
have a text field and a button here you
can see that they're on top of each
other right now because we are in a
vertical layout if we wanted to have
them next to each other we could put
them in a
horizontal layout like this
and
again build this and they will now get
shown next to each other
okay so that takes care of creating and
showing components the last kind of key
piece of information that we need to
build an application is how do we add
uh interaction
we can do that by listening to events so
in our case we can take the button and
add a click listener on it
so whenever somebody clicks on this
button we could go ahead and say let's
add
a new component so we'll add a new
paragraph just a plain paragraph tag
and in there we're gonna say
hello and then we're gonna get the value
from the text field by calling get value
on the text field
and then we can
clear the text field by calling clear on
it like this
so let's go ahead and build
and if all works out we should be able
to now go in here i can type in my
name click on this
and we can see the greeting here
and just to kind of show you that we are
actually building a modern web
application this isn't like a java
applet in disguise or anything like that
let's take a look at what actually gets
generated here
here in the
source
so you can see that
the components here map pretty much one
to one to what you see here so bottom
vertical layout matches the vertical
layout here the horizontal layout has a
bottom text field and avon button so all
the components in the von ui library are
just plain
web components meaning that they're
essentially custom html tags that we've
defined
so they run in any modern browser
without the need of any plugins or
anything else so as far as the browser
is concerned this is just a normal web
application we just happened to define
the ui in java all right so now that we
know the basics let's go ahead and build
a simple address book type of
application where we have a form on top
we persist people into the database and
then we show them in a data grid
so for that we're going to first of all
create a entity that we can use to
persist so i'm going to call this a
person
a
person like i said will be an
entity and an entity needs an id and
we're going to use a
generated value like this and this will
be a
private long id
then we will have a
private string for
first name
private string for last name
and i pray
private
string for
email
surprisingly hard to type and talk at
the same time right so we're going to
generate getters and setters for these
and that takes care of our
basically a data model
then we'll create a repository so that
we can persist and fetch these from the
database
and this we can call
person repository
and here i'm using spring data as the
repository so we can extend from the
jpa repository the type we have is a
person
and the key
uh the id key is of type long
all right
so now that we have a data model and a
repository what we can do is we can make
that repository available to us in the
ui by injecting it here so just using
spring auto wiring in our ui
and we can call this our repository
we can save this into a field so that we
have access to it throughout the view
and
then let's start building out this
uh ui so like i said i want on the top a
forum for entering the first name last
name and email and then on the bottom we
want a data grid that shows those
so we can
actually start by let's define all those
ui components so
private
text field for first name will be a new
text field with a caption
first
name like that
and then we'll do the same for
last name
for email we could use a text field but
there is a even more specific email
field that we can use
uh email field like this
and that just kind of validates that
we're actually inputting an email
all right so we have those
and then we're going to use a bottom
concept of a binder a binder lets us
connect a ui component the ui input
field with a data model field
so we're going to create a
binder
let's type person and we'll just call
this binder and initialize this to a new
not hibernate binder but a
bottom binder
there and this will take in a person
class
here
all right so now we have all the kind of
ingredients that we need for this
the
other thing that we wanted was a grid
for displaying things so we can also go
ahead and
initialize a new
datagrid object
again of type person
call this grid and initialize this to a
new
grid like this and also pass in the
person class
all right so now we actually have all
the
all the ingredients that we need to
build this ui
so let's go ahead and add the components
here so we're going to first of all add
the form and i'm going to split that out
into a separate method
just to keep things clear here and let's
create the method there
and the second thing that we're going to
add
is this grid
all right
and this should of course not return a
string but a component
because otherwise that's not going to be
something that we can add
all right so for the form essentially
what i want to do is have all those
fields next to each other so we're going
to create a
layout which is a
new horizontal layout
and for the layout we're going to set
the alignment to baseline so
everything's nice and aligned and we're
gonna call
layout.add
and we're gonna
add in all of these so we're gonna add
in first name
last name
email
and then finally we're gonna return
the layout
all right so let's go ahead and build
just make sure that we're on the right
track here so what we should see is that
form up on top and then we should see a
grid below
all right so a good start uh we can see
the form up here and we can see the grid
down below
so one thing that are a couple of things
i want to do first of all let's
rearrange the
the grid columns here and drop the id
from being visible and then let's add a
button here
for actually adding adding people so
for the grid
let's call grid.set columns and then
just define that we want to see the
columns
first name
last
name
and
email like this
then in the form let's create a new
component so let's create a
a add
button this will be a new
button and we'll say add
i want to make the button stand out a
little bit so i'm going to use a theme
variant on it
i'm going to use the button variant of
primary it'll make it help help it stand
out a little bit
and then we can add it here
all right so again let's go ahead and
build this make sure that we're
making some progress
so what you should see again is the
button here and now that the columns
match here
all right so
we created this binder a while back and
what we want to do then is actually
bind the ui fields to those
fields in our model and
if you remember
the person object that we created
there was a reason why i named these
fields
and these fields exactly the same that
helps us use a pretty cool feature of
the binder which allows us to say
point instance fields on this which will
essentially inspect
this layout for fields that match
fields on this model and it will
automatically bind those
together
so that takes care of that now of course
we need to somehow react to this add
button getting clicked so that we can we
can do something about it so for that if
you remember we can add a click
listener and when somebody clicks what
we want to do is we want to
tell the binder to write its content
into a new bean and then we can use the
repository to save that
let's do a little
try catch here
so we'll just try and
catch for a
validation exception
like that it won't do anything about it
but what we want to do is we'll create a
new person
person
then we'll try to call
binder dot
right bean
this person
and then assuming that went well we're
going to call
the repository
to
save it that person
and then finally we need
something that actually updates the grid
and that's something i want to actually
call here as we initialize the view as
well so we're going to extract that into
a method of its own let's call fresh
grid
like this
i'm gonna
create the method
and this one will be very very
straightforward
all that we need to do is call grid
set items tell the grid to get its items
from
calling the repository to find all so
just find everything
in the database and show it in the grid
like this
and
of course now if we use this right now
it would work as long as we're
uh using the app but if we came into an
app that already had some content it
wouldn't get shown so we want to make
sure here in the
in the constructor that we
call this uh refresh grid once on init
all right so
let's build and see what happens
if everything went well
we should now be able to use this so we
should be able to
or i should be able to type in my name
to go out in com
and click on add and it shows up here
all right very cool um one thing i could
have done here to improve the ux a
little bit
is to once everything is done here i
could
say binder dot
read bean with a new person so
essentially clearing it
like that
and we could also do some
small ux tweaks here like for the add
button
we could
add
a click shortcut
that's
uh enter
uh no not eject
and tur like that
so now uh we once we build this i should
be able to add new people more
effectively so let's let's go
take a look here so see
test
test
test at test.com hit enter and sure
enough
test2
test2
world.com
there we go
all right so there you have it a very
straightforward way of building modern
web apps 100 in java
von is a battle tested framework it's
been
around for years and years and there are
a lot of big companies building a big
software with it so if you haven't had a
chance to try it out yourself yet
go to either spring initializer or to
start.bond.com and create your own first
project and just give it a go thanks for
watching bye